do you ever ever step on me like that
again well I'm toying with nature I'm
trying to drop romance and you're
standing on my hand bro no stop stop
telling me to stop Madness not this
attack
[Music]
anyway guys anyway girls what you doing
what you're saying you already know what
time it is it's the best part of the
show
let's pause first of all let's not tell
them that the first
first second of the show is the best
part of the show it's one of your
favorite parts of the show it's your
second favorite part of the show it's
your second favorite part of the show
and yeah as per usual juicy wussy the
question of the day was what's the worst
rejection you've ever heard slash said
as per usual dripping down the chin
choose juice
real them off yeah yeah just reading
yeah so worst rejection you've ever
given or received yeah okay cool cool
unfortunately you've gone asked like a
sucked malteser
wow my mom said my mom said I can't say
yes to you because you're a liability
raw I like your ability ability not even
a bad influence a liability
you're not my type what's your friend's
number
I couldn't hear that I promise you now
yeah yeah yeah I couldn't hear that joke
physically could it do you know how many
girls have sledding slid into my DMs and
been like if you had single
what
what are you actually doing here bro
what are you doing here oh like
foohead's my favorite but like you're
actually not bad
what
get out thanks got my DMs facts you got
my DMs jeez bro
can we be together she replied my
enemies would laugh at me
enemies not even my boys I just say a
little suck my enemies would laugh at me
that's impossible my enemies would laugh
at me that's mad you're a jerk that's
Madness to me wow
my boy confessed his love to a girl and
she said anyways
this isn't even funny bro anyway she
laughed and said anyway let's continue
anyways
a girl said I had a nice sorry a guy
said I had nice tits I said thanks my
boyfriend thinks so too he pushed me
over
laughs
that's hilarious he pushed me can't
handle rejection they really really
can't push to me pushed me over you know
jokes
told my ex I wanted him back and he
replied that's funny you're the second
person to tell me that
I just left it like that she would have
lost her mind
pulled ahead lost her mind look picked
up the phone three or four times looked
at the same message I can't believe this
is me she replied something heinous Brad
go but she took her time with it 100
yeah paragraph yeah a paragraph a
paragraph you know what's actually funny
that's what I said yeah do you know
what's actually funny with the read more
at the bottom oh I probably yeah I'm not
reading that I'm not reading that she's
going to be living yeah yeah knives
[Laughter]
toaster on the side of it
it's hilarious hilarious
asked her to go to the prom with me she
started suggesting other people I should
go with
that's not funny bro that's actually not
funny bro I remember in um Mrs yeah 11
obviously prom yeah I was in year 11.
and the person I wanted to ask out I
think she already been asked because
the person I wanted to go with was my ex
at the time oh okay because we had a
tank broke up and then I was single
again obviously
um but I wanted to ask her but I can't
remember I can't remember how the
situation went but I didn't end up
asking I asked that I asked another
chick called Audrey
um she was cool but it wasn't my first
choice you know what I mean but it was
also one of them ones where it was it
was jarring because
ah I
I really didn't have much choice because
when you would ever know bro lyrics
have been sick
early bro and I'm thinking who asked my
ex then because I'm a bit live you can't
have been one of the boys
wow who did ask her I can't remember
black I swear and I was like why did you
dump her
this brings us back to the patreon
episode all right go on
she said she had a dream that I cheated
on her so she just dumped you because
she just went and [ __ ] up this was the
um not even WhatsApp this was a text
message SMS SMS yeah yeah she spent
credit on it yes I had a dream that you
I had a dream that you cheated on me and
I'm thinking pardon I can't remember
what the back and forth was but long
story short I did cheat on her but the
the maddest thing the maddest thing
yeah yes brother yes how did you know
yes bomb
was the softest thing I'd ever squeezed
I couldn't believe it brother it's the
maddest thing about that whole situation
is she obviously
obviously wasn't a dream like she
obviously found out yeah I was lying
around it was a dream Elijah said it was
a dream but the maddest thing was the
chick I'm not obviously hear him say her
name
she rolled around in the same Circle as
my ex like tomato yes yeah later with my
ex similar circles similar friendship
groups so they're always hanging out
with each other I think they weren't in
the same form class because I think my
ex was in my phone class the other chick
wasn't
um but it was weird because
if if the roles were reversed
and I said to my or me and you are me of
you boys in secondary school right and I
found out through hearsay or through
murmurs like you've banged my missus I'm
not messaging my girl I've had a dream
that you banged one of my friends so
this is done we have to talk about gonna
you have to Source I'm gonna come into
form tomorrow and there's gonna be a
ring of fire bro and I'm gonna be
standing in the middle so it has to
happen yeah someone's not leaving
something has to happen you know what I
mean so the way you're partnered out
with her was just was just so weird so
when she said I had a dream I was like
I'm not even insane yeah just let me go
yeah I'm not defending myself yeah just
let me go but yeah Play-Doh buddy
squeeze
he held a squeeze but anyway back to it
what's the worst rejection you've ever
said slash heard
I said hi she said bye
just like that wow hi bye
he wrote a love letter and his friend
returned it all ripped up and some bits
blew away in the Wind
ah
Hearts break
not even mad but people think like doing
the most is always the right idea
doing the most is always the right idea
this little swinger if she's not feeling
me I've done four pages of This Love
Letter cover to cover back to back yeah
yeah yeah like come on man she's gonna
she's gonna read it she's gonna be yeah
yeah never in a million years came back
ripped up my boys like here and some
just scattered off no no no no no no no
no no my poem yeah no no no no no no no
no no
you'll hear my knee my kneecaps cracking
on the pavement
oh and obviously I have to leave the
school oh Rags Rags because I'm now that
pricked yeah I have to leave to school
bro that's
why you don't proposition anything in
Secondary School
I ran she said yes and I did
I was I'd never been so nervous
I've never been so nervous she said yes
there's no way in school luckily the
girls always ask me boy because there
was no way I was asking anyone nothing
it was single for my entire tenure there
bro it was mid class to class so that we
had the whole minute yeah two minute
walk God I went to her said yes I've ran
downstairs in my classroom Ronald
my whole world was different but Like A
Champion yeah that afternoon wow yeah
anyways back to it I thought we were
dating so I called him babe he said I
needed to calm down I'm now asthmatic
I thought we were days I called him babe
the man said yo yo yo down with that
babe stuff
yo
bro bruh you can't be calling me babe
calm yourself I'm now asthmatic she just
had an asthma attack on the spot she has
to she's like actually no no no no no no
no no no no no no no sorry no
uh at a bar my friend was talking to a
guy and he said no offense but I think I
can do better
oh that's actually horrible
that's actually horrible someone
couldn't say I Can Do Better no offense
I know you're you're thinking this is
going well I genuinely think I can do
better like I'm seeing what's around and
I'm thinking this isn't meeting this
isn't me I rate myself higher than this
you're not me tonight and I'm sorry yeah
so let me just cut this short now
how can you say no offense that's all
the effects I'm offended
oh
next one you'll never be a priority to
me
it's true facts bro
we both know the only reason I'm around
you is because you've got a table and
balls
oh this is in a class this is in a dance
a man's just in the air yeah do you know
what I mean
the fight yes
you like it yeah you like it yeah look
at that what do you want would you would
you what I got you yeah where's your
where's your girls
where's your girl's gone
you tell them to leave all over a bit
just me and you yeah huh
yeah nah bro she said big man you do
realize the only reason I'm here is
because you've got a table and Bottles
that's it get your hand off of me get
your hand off me get your lips away from
my ears yeah put your lips away from my
ear you're spitting yeah you're spitting
shut up pass me the bottle or piss off
my table you know I couldn't hear that
those magpies bro they're horrible
magpies the maggies they're horrible bro
jokes
dressed up in lingerie for him and he
just laughed at me oh Jesus wept I can't
be seen in public with you
oh
I found oh that's true
do you know that reminds me of what what
should I say
oh God it's so funny because actually
when we talk about this table I had a
specific Club in my head in Manchester
okay and um in that same Club was there
was a Ting is it Panacea yeah it was
fantasy I know it was Fantasia
I knew it and the the thing with the red
dress do you remember yeah
and I was like bro she's feeling she was
licking a lot he's staring at you just
deep throat in his lollipop and I was
like yeah
damn bro Jesus
this thing's filthy yeah and you're like
bro
there's mine from working there they
could never find out
[Music]
she was voluptuous boy oh she squeezed
in that dress but she was ready to show
you yeah yeah she was ready to give her
all yeah she would have rocked my world
I'd be like yeah no one could ever find
that out bro it's not gonna happen
tonight
wow what a day that's so funny what a
day that was a funny day
oh Jesus is it Panacea that's hilarious
to me it's exactly where it was
man said I'd only hit that on a slow
night
wow bro heinous on a slow night
not even on the [ __ ] on a slow night he
must rate himself boy oh wow she said if
we need to set up the squat rack at the
same height mind your business fair
enough mind your business
that's horrible man your sister is a
hundred percent better looking than you
don't you ever forget that
ever forget that ever forget that
people can't talk to people like that do
you know what I'm saying people cannot
talk to people like that they literally
can't dangerous yeah but they just have
no fear of consequence bam don't you
ever forget that oh yeah that would
slice my nose off my face
don't you ever forget that don't let a
day go by with that doesn't cross your
mind
your sister's banging yeah you're mid
bro
he asked me for my number and I wasn't
interested so I started speaking another
language
it's a good tactic that is yeah fair
enough to be a tactic yeah it works
sometimes certain amount if you're
paying enough I don't care Spanish
Portuguese whatever I'm drinking my
phone duo lingo say it in here and it
will translate because I'm getting your
number
say it in it
[Laughter]
that's jokes bro facts if you're bagging
enough say it to the [ __ ] microphone
shut up translate the whole thing
like what time it is
move like your hairline and take a
couple steps back please
same thing people can't talk to people
like that yeah yeah move like your
hairline take a couple steps back please
oh I'm scrapping you I'm scrapping you
bro
oh it's tough God loves a Trier I don't
step off
sitting right here
step out
if you don't know that movie then
whatever in it
he said another time another life you
would be my butterfly kiss my teeth just
say no and move on
Another Time Another Life you would be
my butterfly I know this is an African
oh only African men love to do our
poetry
heinous won't be my butterfly wow
another time another life AKA I've got a
wife and a couple kids yeah but if you
wanna if you're calm with it we can we
can smash yeah we can smash but we can
never be anything else we can never be
more than alive my butterfly just say no
and move on uh pretended to be deaf and
mute more than once I was doing up sign
language with my friends
geez bro don't say no literally just say
no
she said I'd love to but my Cancer's
terminal
so yeah again a certain amount will be
like it's fine how long have we got
we how long have we got six months three
months a year how long because tonight's
all that matters yeah tonight we're
gonna be here tomorrow I don't care
a guy arrived to pick me up from a date
and I sent my mum out to tell him I
wasn't feeling it
can you imagine he's running I'll run
through that front door
I'd drive off immediately as soon as I
see I'm on working out driving off
as soon as I'm walking out and driving
off I'm I think I wouldn't drive off I'd
be like what's going on bro I'm pretty
sure I've never seen that man before
right yeah
I'm saying all this stuff I will I'll be
paralyzed yeah right as soon as I see
I'm walking down the thing I'll be
paralyzed so I think she's gonna tell me
to [ __ ] off is she like what scared now
she can tell me she's going to be five
minutes like what's going on not even I
thought you were gonna say she she's not
feeling well no she's not feeling it
it's bro I'm sorry she's really just not
feeling it
the March had to come out that's I'm not
doing that for my daughter my child face
your own fears no way in hell face your
own fear she would have she would have
played Public Safety she would have pled
Public Safety
she right mum I don't I don't know this
guy
if I reject him I don't know what he's
going to do he's not gonna do nothing to
you I don't know what's going to do to
me the man would have been like hell
yeah there's no way it's a less there's
no way my mum would never go out for me
never in a million years would you got
for me
that's jokes I don't think Mom would
either she won't take it seriously yeah
no why would it take me seriously look
at me once and just look carry on
watching EastEnders whatever she's doing
you're chatting [ __ ] to me and you're
interrupted
that's hilarious
all right I've got yeah I've got a
couple more worst um rejection you've
ever heard or said
um a guy tried to get close to me in a
club I grabbed his hand span him around
and pushed him away
there was so much chest where are your
manners
where are your manners bro so much chest
I don't care how often this happens to
you where are your manners I'm trying my
best I don't know what else to do you're
paying and I'm trying to let you know
what would you rather me do grab my hand
spun me around like a yacht and just
sent me on my way he almost sent me back
to where I came from Madness fam yeah
she would have seen a full glass of
water flying across the I don't even
like say let's say
she would spun me around and I would
have walked straight to the bar and she
would have carried on whining like
I'm a bad [ __ ] so I'm out of nowhere
class was smack my head
her and a girl's disheveled fam that's
the thing wow jokes
met a girl in the club she asked me for
my insta she saw it looked to me and
said nah
just said nah yeah boy but you've seen
me in 3D yeah I'm here now and you asked
me for my insta so there's something you
liked about me yeah but then she saw
where you were socially yes so she saw
where you were socially You've Got 2 000
pictures and 150 you're following 9 000
people yeah you've got 150 followers ah
get away from it yeah get away for a bag
yeah and all you do is post you post any
and everything yeah yeah I don't want to
be no one cares about you I'm not
associated yeah
I just don't see you as a man
straight up I just don't see you as a
man if you had honestly honestly she's
black for starters
she is
because she's got so much gold
do you know how much gold that takes I
just don't see you yeah I'm looking at
you and I just don't see a man like what
I Envision as a man it's just not you I
just can't see it and maybe that's
because we're boys yeah I just don't see
it someone will someone might definitely
not me yeah speak
bro Peak you can't ever tell you because
you're moving to her yeah what can you
do also yeah there's nothing you can say
she's got the upper hand I'll just
spider and dip I would have to spider
yeah a guy told me twice that he loved
me but I pretended like I didn't hear it
twice I love you just
I said I love you
[Music]
this is definitely gang signs deaf and
Meat Boy I'll be doing upside like are
we screaming at
what are you screaming at stop yeah I
couldn't
we were at the park and he tried to pick
up a flower for me I stepped on both his
hand and the flower and said stop
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
just fam stop
wow can you imagine looking up at uh
what's your your finger yeah you crushed
under her sandal
she says are you looking up there's a
sun gland in your eyes and she's like
stop looking down and you stop my other
hand grab her ankle she's got she's on
the floor she's not doing this is this
is irrelevant but people who know I'll
do an imminary role on her an imminary
role
is a jiu jitsu move right where like
you like hook your arm yeah round
um so say her legs like say her legs
here I wrap my arm around the on around
the back of her ankle into the inside of
her knee I'm with you and then like you
lift your legs up and drag it down yeah
yeah you snap her ankle
you snap her ankle
oh as soon as she's crossed my hand I'll
transition straight into it I'll
transition straight into the imanari
roll
get the [ __ ] off me the park will go mad
oh 100. I don't know what here
and I'll tell her straight when she's
disheveled yeah snapdrank on the floor
do you ever ever step on me like that
again well I'm toying with nature I'm
trying to drop romance and you're
standing on my hand bro no stop stop
telling me to stop Madness it's not this
attack facts Madness last one
huh I thought you liked me him I think
you overestimate the value of our
interactions oh good no need to break it
down I think you overestimate the value
of our interactions it's a high biting
you're doing too much Geez Louise
just because I told you thank God it's
Friday it doesn't mean we're Partners
bro I thought you liked me no one should
ever ever ever ever ever ever say that
sentence ever yeah I thought you liked
me yeah that's that's tough you're
seeing stuff the opposite person's not
seeing how did I miss this fact where
was I Vamp it's the moment it's my worst
fear being the position I thought I
thought she was down bro we're watching
two different games yeah we're watching
two different games if you think that
wow that's Madness to me
wow wow wow wow but yeah that was a
threat that's a crazy threat yeah yeah
um two things
first
I've I remember my worst rejection oh
hit me my first rejection or my worst
rejection worse rejection
um I'm trying to think I think it was
one of my first and last and worst all
wrapped up into one I think I've
definitely taught it on the story before
is about painting Lauren
painting Lauren I went to the school
down the road from me okay she was a
year above me okay we went to some party
and she was there and my boy John I'll
bet his name is boy John went up to her
yeah
said some stuff
in our ear I watched the whole thing on
the Dance Floor sets of stuff in it
because I remember my blood pressure
raised yeah because I thought oh he's
making me yeah yeah always sneaking
because I trust my team he's actually
thinking it's crazy it's crazy how
Amanda and women do it as well they
fixate themselves on the person that
they fancy it's my take it's probably
She's mine that's my problem
who in God's name do you think you are
who in God's name I understand dibs yeah
yeah 100 bro yeah and he was he was
whispering it in they were giggling and
I remember thinking that you man had
taking that piss out on me yeah we're
fighting yeah you know I'm in love with
her yeah yeah and um
because I think okay so if no one said
the story before I've definitely thought
of it it was literally like two years
ago I told the story
um
there was a girl I fancied the hell out
of who went to the school down the road
from me and because I lived near that
school I would see her walking home
every day I'm talking from year seven to
a year 11. every day I was obsessed with
this guy didn't know her name I used to
call it painting and then someone else
who was in my uh year told me
um what her name was okay her name was
Lauren okay painting Lauren good Lord I
was obsessed with her anyway
I went to a party that she was at
everyone in my circle knew that I
fancied disco and she was a year older
so I knew it was long anyway this is we
were in six forms I was near 12 years
and year 13.
I spoke to her the week of because I saw
him passing my boy same boy that was
that yeah yeah inner ear yeah he was
there and he was like that's your thing
and I was like bro just leave it and he
was like you have to say sorry and I was
like what do you want me to say bro and
he was like you just have to introduce
yourself let her know who you are like
chivalry is not dead you know what I'm
saying just don't be a gentleman yeah
yeah and then I was like there's
literally no there's no possible
scenario I'm doing that he was like well
obviously you're a [ __ ] and obviously
in year 12 you can't hear that word and
you're like all right we'll say that
let's go chat to another yeah fam went
over there well go on she was like hi
literally high and I was like that's
that's broken step one I'm broken
already the gravity that hit me in that
moment you know an anime where the lines
are pointing down yeah and all of a
sudden my outline got bald the pressure
in that situation was hitting me bro
yeah she was like hi I'm mob psycho yeah
yeah she was like looking left or right
and you can see her face getting a bit
red she was embarrassed and I was like
all of a sudden I realized what am I
doing what am I doing what am I doing
what am I doing I was like hi I'm James
and she was like hi she's even she
didn't even tell me her name she was
like hi she was like do you go here
do you go here to the school that I've
admired you from from yesterday yeah do
I go here yeah yeah do I do you go here
and I was like no I go to my school that
I went to uh and she was like oh right
because yeah I don't think I've ever
seen you before and I was like
yeah anyway
um I I see I've seen you a lot I just
want to introduce myself and she was
like okay and I was like okay bye didn't
know what to do didn't know what to say
I was like I don't know what I expected
to do once I got here yeah so I was like
all right bye run across the road like
like you said in your ex I ran across
the road to my boys
terrified didn't look back and my boys
like what's he saying you're gonna look
back if I didn't look back is that what
she's saying I was like oh she's on it
ah obviously she's on it
he was like yeah yeah yeah went to a
party the next week seen her there and
then my boys like there's your tank my
heart was pounding he's like he's gonna
pressure me to tattoo again of course
because I told her she's on it of course
he's gonna pressure me and he was like
gosh I promise you now I'm gonna have a
couple drinks in it let me get a
Strongbow in me yeah yeah yeah and then
we'll see let's say this I look over his
inner ear they're giggling I was like he
snakes me he snake me and that's fine
obviously he comes back over and he's
like bro
I was chatting her up about you and I
was like you know you're trying to spot
shut your mouth sit down on something
sit down sit down
don't leave make eye contact with me
yeah what's she saying head down what's
she saying what she said he's like bro I
was talking to her told her um obviously
I'm your boy she looked over she
recognized you for another day she was
like oh like tell him to shout me
um later for a dance and I was like guy
and he was like bro bro
spotted him and I was like [ __ ] gang
fam had my little paint yeah that's all
we could get by then
um I didn't know about spirits back then
yeah I might look a point chewing gum in
I was like say less my boy's like bro at
this point they're playing like slow
jams so it's not one Jagged Edge is on
Jagged it was on and he was like bro
it's not one never Good Luck Charlie
yeah yeah good luck charm bro
um so I was like say less one over there
my legs were jelly brother jelly one
over down I was like hi AI
fam she showed me the same faces the
week before she was like hi
and I was like oh I've come to I've come
to collect my dance
she said
you've never seen anyone more confused
than she was in that moment right now
she said what
fat I was thinking I I said it clearly I
know the music's loud but I know I'm
speaking Yeah Yeah there's no way she
has no idea why I'm here yeah I turned
around my brother's laughing my boy was
in hysterics hands and knees hands and
knees I couldn't breathe on the floor
slapping the floor I was like no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
needed to swallow you yeah I needed
someone to take me out I needed to look
and see someone like this on me
and he's the fox demon just swallow me
whole
um
I was like and I immediately realized
what situation I got myself in so I said
oh
I talked to you the other day yeah she
was like oh yeah I remember and I was
like I just went to see if you want to
have a dance and she found she said how
old are you
I'm only a year younger than her she was
like how old are you and I was like I'm
in year 12 and she was like yeah
no bro like no no no no no no and I was
like cool cool yeah
[Laughter]
walk straight back to my seat my boy was
howling I'd have to I would leave the
party yeah straight away I want to kill
myself here straight away that's why I
would leave yeah
because I'd want to kill myself yeah I'd
have to leave James I've never
experienced anything that bad and that's
why I'd never spoken to a girl before
then and I've literally never spoken to
August
trauma trauma
[Laughter]
well I've never I've not chose to go
since that day yeah the worst experience
of my life oh wow worst experience of my
life wow yeah the thing is I remember
you obviously saying that on the Pod but
when you say it again I'm there like oh
bro I'm like shaking mine was not even
my worst one the one that I can remember
I've said on here as well before
um was when I was in year eight and
there was a chick she was a baddie she's
still a baddie now actually
um and
yeah I I fancy the [ __ ] out of her but
she was older than me but I didn't know
at the time I don't think and I was
talking talking we were in the same
class same here this was year eight and
I went up to her I was like yo I think I
think I said something along the lines
of think of pre or paying or whatever
this is in Nigeria as well when I was in
Nigeria
um yeah what you're saying I want to try
to do a tea I want a movie
yeah
no it's just like
I just don't date guys younger than me
and I'm thinking you're three months Max
Max older than me what are we talking
about you're lying to my face what are
you talking about wow but yeah that's
the that is the only one I can remember
vividly because
one I remember being like Oh like you're
absolutely gorgeous and I went out with
my bedroom afterwards say less yeah come
on man but yeah
um anyway guys welcome back yeah sure
happy uh it's shoot by the time it comes
out I think it comes out on boxing day
so I hope you guys had a banging
Christmas
um yeah man I hope you got everything
you asked for and yeah man we're here
again um obviously guys if you enjoy the
content and you want to see a little bit
more of it head on over to patreon.com
shits and gigs it's gonna cost you a
very very very humble three pound a
month 10p a day just run the pizza sng
and guys you get over three years worth
of uh uncensored and very minuscule
unedited uh
episodes and a massive backlog and you
get an episode every single Thursday
from us as well as our Infamous Discord
chat where all the cult babies come
together and just spread love do up
family stuff go and
do [ __ ] together and yeah man just just
the vibe it's a complete another vibe um
also guys if you are listening on any of
the podcast apps please drop us a little
follow and uh please give us a rate in
five stars as preferable
but whatever you need to say say it with
your chest guys and uh lastly guys on
YouTube we are steamrolling through the
subs at the minute on YouTube so please
help us out subscribe to the channel
like the video if you like the video and
chirps 18 in the comments guys we need
the breeding grounds for the cult
cabin okay right
without any further ado
my ombre fired for eggs are going to hit
you guys with some knowledge today all
right so let's jump straight into it you
might have seen this one before so I'm
not too sure but man known as Playboy
King has been married 87 times and
planned to marry again that's impossible
and plans to marry again I'm not
laughing this is possible
it's literally impossible an Indonesian
man has a reputation for getting married
to 87 so getting married 87 times to 46
different women always just been
marrying the same yes twice apparently
he intends to get married once more he
occasionally married two ladies at once
a rice farmer from West Java named Khan
61 claims to have married 87 times and
is prepared to remarry one of them
he claims that he married a girl who was
two years older than him at the age of
14 and that their Union lasted for
nearly two years according to Oddity
Central Khan quickly got married to all
of the women he dated because he didn't
want them to feel like a fling he
married them all despite some of his
relationships just lasting a week or two
this is him in quotes my reason is that
I also didn't want to play with women's
feelings and let her learn other
people's children rather than committing
rather than committing immorality it is
better that I get married what is he on
brother I died about Playboy
what's he is autistic he has to be like
science yeah yeah that's not making any
sense
14. yeah first of all 14 is a little
playground wedding trees yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah kiss Chase what's the thing
yeah yeah don't tell me you got married
at 14 bro
87th man said he didn't want to play
with their feelings so he married them
instead yeah all of this is jargon and
lies and I'm
frankly fed up a bit that's all jargon
in Indonesia I don't know what rules
they have over there yeah yeah you just
stop that's boring that that is
it's just something you just don't hear
yeah what is that why would you even
entertain why would you put yourself
through that why would you even
like you're gonna have your friends your
family or whoever invited to said
wedding not even once not twice not
three 87 times you I wouldn't come to
your second wedding
I love you
I want to come to your second wedding
and especially if it's the same thing
imagine
no oh bro I'm marrying X again
we didn't work out last time but this
I've got a good feeling this time's the
one James this time's the one I'm gonna
prove it don't marry her just do it our
good face yeah yeah yeah do this
relationship I'm good forever not
dressing up again do it my whole I gave
you my whole day bro
I'm not again not again if you love me
don't do it don't invite me bro just
have a witness there and do whatever you
want to do it would have it would have
to be a sign thing not it could be a
little registry sign gang lips go yeah
yeah that's um that's crazy it is man
them don't don't be stupid yeah come on
guys this that don't be Playboy Kings
that's the worst thing I've heard what's
going on feathers we're going to take a
very very very quick break
to indoctrinate you into the man's kid
family okay facts so this episode of
shits and gigs is brought to you by our
favorite producers of ball trimmers guys
we've known are not a lot of ball
trimmer producers and these by far are
our favorite it is of course manscape
the global leaders in below the waist
grooming come on and they are leaving
2022 with a clear mind and clear balls
and manscape wants to help you do so
with a special offer all you need to do
is use the code sng Sierra November golf
for 20 off and free shipping at man
escaped.com com take the leap into the
new year and join the 7 million men are
your boys included who already trust
Landscapes and let's get back to the
episode thank you very much okay I've
got a little story hit me your boy's got
a story
so this happened to me
as we're recording so this
um happened to me yesterday
so let me set the scene for you bro okay
Daddy got humbled yesterday
and I needed to I clearly need to be
dropped a few pegs okay but Daddy got
humbled yesterday okay and it was
horrible
so check this out right so I'm out let
me set the scene I'm out I'm doing a
little bit of shopping
um
I might do a little bit of Christmas
shopping
and your boys obviously your boy spent a
little bit of money in it yeah so I've
got a couple technicolored bags yeah
bright colored bikes yeah boys looking
like Joseph in a technical Dreamcoat
yeah I'm just at it yeah yeah yeah yeah
swinging yeah yeah the shop is complete
and I'm walking back to my car swinging
bags
gas pump
I look forward and there's a group of
girls they're actually quite young
um but there's a group of girls staring
at me pointing and giggling but like in
a cute way not in a like a yuck way okay
just in like a
um so it's like a little gossipy thing
okay
um and so obviously you boycott too and
then light skin activated
yeah
life skeleton came in activate lights
can activate you boys
yes me and Rob literally there
[ __ ] sake my man
of mine can't even come out in public
anymore
call me with the bags and everything
lips
they call me off guard spending bags
it's straight
so bro yeah my chest raised my eyes
squinted yeah
I thought this is long yeah I looked
again and these manages
these things
oh God yeah yeah here we go so I took
cover yeah step to my left before let me
get out of their line of sight let me
just get on with my day because I'm too
cool for school fam as I've walked off I
I peek to them one more time
they're still looking where I was
standing a second ago same thing just
I looked behind me Central C is standing
right behind me
fam
boyant Central City standing directly
behind me he's not even looking
he was staring in the sky his head was
in the clouds bro he was just Smiling
Teeth shining looking at migrating geese
Society he was just staring up
through hat and then he dropped humbled
humbled
the wind that left my lungs yeah
bro bro
I sank into the shadows and just ran to
my car the man said lightly activated
activated I love it man
come on man it's Wednesday afternoon let
me just do a light shot no harassment in
our I know I'm popular but allow me ah
come on man Central Central C and you
know what's actually dread it had to be
someone so much more famous than me
it actually had to be actually so I'm so
much more famous to me to be like wow
you're nobody brother get to your car
shut up
take your dirty bags to your car and
shut up oh was he on his days now he's
with his boys okay that's hilarious oh
yeah humbling moment
I've never felt anything like it I
promise you now I've never felt anything
like it humbling and I was like wow
I got in my car and stared at myself in
the rear view instead of my eyes in the
review and said remember who you are I
felt like move you know what moved
faster I was talking to Simba in the
clouds and remember who you are that's
exactly that's I had a Mufasa moment bro
wow moment I stared at myself in a
review and said wow remember who you are
brother you're not anyone that's
hilarious
wow I'm so sorry bro he wasn't even
paying attention humbled I was gassed
off these little girls yeah he wasn't
even paying attention
yeah
he doesn't need any of that
but the light he activated is so
hilarious and the dreading is they only
clocked him because he's wearing a mask
they only caught him because he quickly
took down his mask to unlock his phone
and then put it back up that's all it
took to clock him I wasn't even wearing
a mask my face was ah
my face was
not you me
brother with the bags got away I'm
trying to see sench he wasn't even
holding his own bags
too hard look at me he wasn't even on
his own back that's a different level
his bedrooms are holding his bags that's
a different level of money and I I
couldn't grab another bag
[Laughter]
oh it was horrible oh yeah worst
experience I've had um but factually
needed it humbling wow oh wow wow sorry
brother yeah yeah I will never ever ever
complain about someone stopping in the
street again I promise you that now I'll
probably complain immediately after that
but I I can't complain about again
because I was like wow wow wow wow wow
they literally can't see me
wow it's literally one of them it was
literally one of them yeah our spatial
awareness fixed up immediately I'm so
sorry I had to be Ugg
um so you've got trash news for us now
news for you man uh right
an LAPD cop was arrested for sharing
nude pictures of his officer's wife with
other officers at work
hey
an lap cop was arrested for sharing nude
pictures of his officer white sorry of
his officer wife with other officers so
basically his wife so his wife works for
the napd as well and he's just sharing
and he's like brother under that uniform
human don't want to know
and Manchester fam of his wife but has
no shame no shame no shame no respect
the pics there on
the Third
no there's only a police car
you see his skin she must be back yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I said is she
there
just the face of sight that's a little
silhouette let me see yeah yeah because
the imagination
he's willing to break vows for This Rags
she must be banging banging
so yeah um
Brady Lamas 45 is facing a six facing
six misdemeanor raps after his wife
spotted one of the pictures
um and picture on his phone as part of
the group chat oh my God in quotes I did
not I didn't know the photos were taken
of me and I didn't give consent for any
of the photos to be shared with anyone
he didn't know they were taken man's
taking secret photos of his own misses
bro and put him in I thought he was just
showing on the phone put him in a group
chat chat she alleged he took the
explicit pictures during a doctor's
visit after she had a breast a lot no no
no and sent them to others before and
after shot no no no no no no no no no no
no
my husband my own husband is a predator
and he prayed on me she wrote in the
court papers
I would have preferred they punched me
in the face oh Rags I also worried about
how my husband would um I also worried
about how my husband would react when he
found out I had discovered his horrible
disturbing acts the images were
distributed between December 29 2021 and
January 24th in a group chat on a
messaging app they were discovered to be
his wife on January 30th so weeks a
month a whole month she didn't realize
oh products that's basically it that's
basically that's mad man said
she alleged he took the pictures of of
the breasts at the doctor's visit
before and after shots so man's basic
Okay cool so now I've got a better
conceptualization of what's actually
going on here so man's
got a misses
who also works for the LAPD yeah he's in
the lads group chat yeah man said I'm
gassed baby girl's getting her boobs
done today
went over to the doctors
as homeboys doing the little the little
markers on the ticket managed to
snapping pigs before
sent in the before
after bang bang said one afternoon
what's the one on it
fam on a little low-key something so
this is my wife this is what my wife's
Tigs looked like before and this is what
they look like after but damn you're
applaud to me you're why he's a predator
this guy's got no shame bro
he's
he finds gratification in anything
he needs to be he needs to be the leader
of the group yeah and in any form of
approval yeah he's doing it yeah yeah
if he got a single like thumbs up
reaction not even a reply
that's all I needed to get my day
started that's what you're saying that's
all I needed to get my day started
because that's Madness that's wild not
even a random thing that you're banging
or a random thing that you may bang your
wife your wife pre and post operation
and she found out a month after that
I've been spreading my tea in the group
chat yeah that's insane bro that's
actually worse than just I thought it
was nudes I thought she was sending him
nudes and then she he was like yeah and
then I heard it was in the group chat
and I was like okay that's worse and
then I heard that it was unsolicited
photos way worse and then I heard it's
in a doctor's surgery pre and post up
brother
he needs to go to jail oh 100 bro
because that that's something a rapist
does yeah
[Music]
sin he has to go to jail that's mad yeah
man just put them in there with bare
motorboat gifts
wow yeah and it's it's so ironic that he
works for the police yeah he has to go
to jail yeah that's the worst thing I've
heard that's Madness that's the worst
you've got one more yeah yeah I've got
one more um trash news so yeah in the
spirit of Christmas that's just
um that's just come and gone before us
Florida man arrested after he allegedly
hit his wife with a Christmas tree after
she asked for help him make after she
asked for help with making dinner
have you seen this one
I thought is it like an old white guy
yeah yeah the first one was a Florida
man it's always Florida sighting bro
that's where the heathens live he was
Florida
um beat her with a Christmas tree
because she asked for help to cook
Christmas dinner
I said what do I look like no I'm
setting up let me read the technique
yeah get out of control yeah yeah
Florida man allegedly pissed
what is it before we get out of control
with the reenactments if we don't know
the facts yeah we do that all the time
you know all the time brother all right
run me the fact so I can reenact
oh
Google Google a Florida man allegedly
threw a Christmas tree at his wife
during an argument that sparked when she
asked him to help make dinner Authority
said how do you throw a Christmas tree
I'm thinking he's strong raise a
lumberjack yeah yeah he cut that tree
down himself
uh Richard Atkinson 52 lost his temper
in a couple in the couple's um Park home
on Monday evening after his wife asked
for help and put us and put a spoon in a
sink accidentally splashing water a
splash him with water sorry
he packed his things and went outside
wait run this spoon thing again he put a
spoon in the sink and smashed himself
well she put a sponge
to be fair I'm sorry to cut you off
that's not
I promise you now or this movie it's me
and my bae are arguing about something
yeah and she's like oh whatever man and
then she just like starts like wow I
can't speak today
my neck back
my face was special or freeze
but you're not gonna throw a Christmas
tree I might bro
because my temper's already oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah what are you doing yeah you're
flat well you're doing dashes spoons up
man
we didn't Dustin spoons up man bro are
you mad that's freezing yeah there's
nothing worse than cold water
ah I got that the other day I nearly
punch someone in the face
I was walking into my yard and it's been
raining recently it's been raining
recently a fat drop went directly down
I said my hand smacked the door
oh there couldn't have been a human next
to me
so yeah I can understand if we've
already been in your lobbying spoons and
it's splashing me yeah and draws it for
Saturday wow wow wow so I'm gonna run
that bit back sorry go on it's all right
uh Richard 52 lost his temper in a
couple's um parkour Monday evening after
his wife asked for help and put a spoon
in the sink accidentally splashing him
with water action packs these things and
went outside to his vehicle before
returning home because he had been
drinking and told his wife to leave
instead
when the wife tried to go deputies say
he shoved her picked up a Christmas tree
that was in the corner of the room and
threw out her striking her he then
allegedly blocked the front door to
Brent her from leaving okay see that's
too much yeah that's you can't start
assaulting people it's scary yeah he
looks terrifying he looks scary brother
that yeah that's that's why I said let
me read the thing before we start
I can see exactly why I did it
I mean I'm obviously joking I know you
are I know you are but it's like
how
this is meant to be like a family
festive period yeah do you know what I
mean all Lady does all Joys or reindeers
and them things there so if I'm asking
for help in the kitchen for the fam yeah
and you're huffing a pup if you have to
do what you want Hufflepuff in it but if
I accidentally throw sight in the sink
and you get a bit of backsplash all of a
sudden you're throwing [ __ ] at me yeah
all of a sudden I'm trying to leave and
you're blocking the door come on
the Block in the door's too much the
Christmas tree's too much it is but hear
me out
Christmas tree first of all we don't
know how big this tree was that's
ornaments and lights and everything we
don't know how big the tree was it could
be fake it could be real we don't know
how big it was it could be a little a
little two foot some yeah right maybe
let's just hear me out okay listen she
says something along the lines of
babe I'm stressed talk to me so okay
let's just say okay let's just say this
I have your homeboy yeah yeah so this is
helpful because now it's my job as home
girl to get you to the point where you
want to throw Christmas tree at me yeah
right let's see if we see if we can do
this yeah yeah yeah so I've decided I'm
doing the most this year okay you're
already vexed yeah because I sent you to
buy everything I said you need to buy
everything and there's literally three
of us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
what are you doing yeah but whatever
have your Christmas so I'm in there I'm
in there now I'm flustered yeah my eyes
are too big for my belly I'm flustered
and I said babe what
babe get in here please I need you why
babe I'm not gonna lie this needs doing
that he's doing I'm tired of having to
do everything by myself yeah but you
wanted all of this you you wanted this
big ass Christmas dinner I told you to
go minimalistic and here we are hear
what you know I don't is that how you
help you know I don't really wow is that
how you help is that how you help no I
don't really do that all you do is nit
picnic picnic I'm trying to I'm I am the
only one in this family who gives a
single [ __ ] I'm actually you know what's
actually mad I'm the only one in this
one who actually gives a [ __ ] so yes
shoot me I'm so sorry in the spirit of
Christmas I actually thought I might be
able to save our marriage by doing the
most as you say we do this yeah shut
your mouth can you come in or help me or
not bro I'm in here I'm in the kitchen
right useless help me help me help me
you're just saying help me what do you
want me to do you're just saying help me
what do you want are you blind are you
literally blind tell me is that in the
oven is that seasoned is there carrots
chops are you blind tell me what you
want me to do and I'll do you know what
you actually you're actually useless you
actually you know what's actually mad
you can't think of yourself you actually
need a woman to tell you what to do
pathetic pathetic pathetic you know what
it's actually pathetic
actually put this in the sink
but you didn't see actually I didn't
even announce anything I didn't announce
yeah go on leave so you've turned around
I feel sorry I find my paws
look back
what did you just throw on well you're
not leaving
what did you do well you're not leaving
you just threw something
throw in something someone throw me
stuff I mean something well throw me
stuff at people yeah yeah
imagine
I'll be right back
she said where are you going I said I'll
be right back
I launched it Javelin ha launch it have
that we're throwing stuff yeah hold that
right she said wow [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] your dinner [ __ ] everything tried
to leave him I said
you're not leaving you finish the dinner
you're not leaving me and you're not
leaving the gears finish cooking this
dinner
we're gonna see you into the new year
yeah finish finish this stupid dinner
that you wanted to cook
what mad yeah he looks scary so we're
throwing stuff at people that's
hilarious
so we're just throwing stuff that's
Madness to me bro Madness to you I've
got a little thread to finish off okay
let's go
all right cool
this was wild all right cool so this
thread
that I saw the other day you probably
you must someone must have sentenced to
you actually fun fact okay guys
little requests before I do this yeah
yeah literally yeah yeah when you send
that stuff yeah yeah either send it to
the SMG page or send it to me or send it
to fuhad there's nothing more jarring
about me getting excited to share
something with my best friend and he's
like yeah yeah I saw it yeah yeah
someone said it to me
and when people are in my DMs like I had
to send it to both of you to make sure
it made it through don't send it to both
of us because if we've if one of us
already it takes it sucks the fun out
yeah it does it sucks the fun out of it
it feels like fake faking laughs he's
all a fake and laugh for production
I can see he's so transparent
that was fake it anyway all right cool
so your question definitely you
definitely saw this what's the most down
bad thing you ever did have you seen
this one maybe what's the most down bad
thing you ever did maybe I saw it but I
didn't like scroll calm
fam D's lot went mad
I drew her in art class and beat to the
drawing yeah the thing is I saw that now
that you've read that I've never seen
that one firm because that was my first
one I drew her in art class and I beat
it to the drawing for us in sanity fam
they get wild we switched we switched
School IDs and when I got home I started
kissing her picture
yo bro lost this is secondary loss this
is definitely Secondary School lost wow
kissing the picture what infatuation
teenage boys lose control through that
wow
wow bro
this one doesn't make sense
I found out her shoe size and I beat to
that number in my head
bro man damn it doesn't make sense
I beat to that number just five five
five five five five five Strokes out wow
I recorded her answering a question on a
zoom call class and I said
Amanda and and then the clap Emoji the
moisturizer emoji
just
I recorded her answering a question on
the zoom class wow yeah down bad
down bad bro wow what's happening wow
bro I took a picture of my cheeks I'm
busted to it while imagining it was hers
no since we have the exact same skin
tone
that's disgusting that's the worst one
I've heard
man squeezed up his cheeks in the camera
and said that's hers and fact what it
doesn't make any sense it's the worst
thing I've ever heard in my life that
was the last one that's this worst thing
I've ever heard in my life took a
picture of his own Yash yeah yeah and
said that that's hers yeah yeah
oh worst thing I've ever heard yeah
worst thing I've ever heard Amanda my
disgrace um oh actually I've actually
got
one more okay I've actually got one more
okay I'm cast I'm gassed right cool
this one was dumb so this is just like a
continuation thing that someone sent me
so
graduate of chemistry but don't know
when the bomb between you and her is
broken
okay fam
graduate of accounting but you can't
tell when your partner's losing interest
okay bro okay graduate ones are the
comments were mad okay gradual of maths
but the story ain't had enough
yeah laughs
gradual of music but can't tell when she
played you like a fiddle
bro
like that
played you like a fiddle paid you like a
fiddle graduate of mass but you still
can't get some
they're doing that
yeah
they're doing up double on Torch wow fam
graduated from Plumbing but you ain't
figured out who's really laying pipe
bro wait figured out you ain't figuring
out who's really laying pipe
they're speak to me like that wow no no
no this ain't Cluedo speak to me nice
speak to me correctly wow
um oh okay
graduate of aerospace engineering but
she didn't think the relationship would
take off that's so dark they're so dumb
graduated in photography but don't know
why she didn't picture a future together
a graduate of medicine but can't realize
when she's sick of you
that's tough that's tough
bro
a graduate of geography but you don't
know when the pic you don't gradual
geography but you don't know if the
pickup line is gonna land
[Music]
so stupid
graduate of architecture still can't get
her support
that's the one that's the one
that's hilarious is this the same thread
bro it's the comments from the same
bread bro wow
wow graduate of culinary arts
but still can't mustered up the will to
get yourself out of this pickle
shut up
graduate of archeology a graduate of
archeology can't say why is she digging
in the past
[Music]
wow hilarious wow graduate of Journalism
but it was breaking news to you
yo yo that's quick weird so funny that's
hilarious graduate of electrical
engineering but don't know when the spot
between us is gone
I expected that one oh God
uh what they got Jesus
all right these are all buttons now
these are the ones with the least likes
yeah you got to stop the top ones were
banging but yeah that's pretty much it
hilarious little Sunday hilarious little
time but anyway guys
as always thank you so much hope you
enjoyed it and um
yeah man
this was paying see you on Thursday
patreon.com
[Music]